infirmier psychiatre soignants de toute
la france il demande à exercer en toute
humanité et dignité
moi je peux vous dire ça va faire 30 ans
que je bosse j'ai jamais vu autant de
contention le malaise est ancien des
gens 1970 dans cet hôpital des soignants
soulever un manque de personnel et le
refrain se répète chaque décennie ou
impossible de mener une véritable
politique de soins nous contentons de
faire un gardiennage dans les années 80
le manque de moyens est générale ajoutez
à celà l'insalubrité dans certains
hôpitaux psychiatriques difficile pour
le personnel de garder le patient au
coeur des préoccupations
cantona mangeant des médicaments qui
sont dictées par des médecins
rien de plus le moi j'ai un diplôme
d'infirmier en psychiatrie je ne fais
rien de plus que fermé ouvrir des portes
on peut pas continuer comme ça je veux
dire manque de personnels locaux
surchargé pour un public sensible en
2004 à pau dans les pyrénées-atlantiques
une infirmière et une aide soignante
sont assassinés l'auteur avait déjà
séjourné trois fois en psychiatrie la
ferme et en lumière le manque criant de
moyens et la surdité de la direction on
lui a demandé des effectifs qu'est-ce
qui nous a répondu économie économie
voilà maintenant me après le drame de
pau le gouvernement ne peut plus
détourner le regard
il ya quand même pas mal de mi-mai
médecin psychiatre et qui me disent on
fait partir des malades parfois un peu
trop tôt ou parfois je n'arrive pas à
recevoir un malade parce que les lits
sont pleins philippe douste-blazy
annonce le plan santé mentale en 2005
au total 1 milles
art d'euros sur cinq ans dont deux cent
mille débloqués en urgence
trois ans après la profession estime que
ce plan est un échec
on a obtenu par exemple un médecin
régulateur de journée mais ça n'a pas
régler la problématique qui fait que
actuellement à les unités d'admission
sont encombrées
cette même année 2008 à grenoble un
étudiant et poignardé par un patient en
fugue
réponse de la ministre de la santé 70
millions d'euros pour renforcer la
sécurité dans les établissements
réaction des psychiatres non merci
il faut des moyens humains et pas des
centres de rétention ou des centres de
prison et pas de stigmatisation en 1975
137 1535 lee était dédiée à la
psychiatrie en hospitalisation complète
gouvernement après gouvernement par
souci d'économie ou de solutions
alternatives
ce chiffre a chuté de 40%
[Musique]